jessie was one of the most promising
disney channel sitcoms of its time the
show was rumored to be the longest
airing disney show ever but got
cancelled after four seasons what went
wrong stay until the end to find the
biggest secret Disney tried to hide from
Jessie fans don't forget to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up if you
love Jessie today we're putting on our
detective hats and exploring the dark
Jessie secrets Disney tried to hide
they pulled an episode did you know that
there's a Jessie episode you'll never be
able to see anywhere Disney was forced
to pull it after many complaints from
the general audience the public signed a
petition to remove the episode that
shamed children with gluten allergies
and Disney was forced to take action in
the episode a child called Stuart is
introduced as being sensitive to gluten
and the show decided to portray him as
annoying and high-maintenance
hands up getting pancakes thrown in his
face and while the studio audience did
laugh parents definitely didn't while we
know Disney loves to highlight certain
lifestyles and make a joke out of the
situation they did take it just a little
bit too far with this storyline again
parents were concerned as they felt this
episode mocked children with food
allergies
after more than 2,000 people had signed
the petition Disney was forced to take
action they later released a statement
saying they deeply apologize that the
episode made some viewers upset and that
they will reevaluate its references to
gluten restrictions of course there were
mixed opinions on the episode and while
some didn't think this was a big deal
but it was a sensitive topic for parents
whose kids already frequently get mocked
for their food allergies have you seen
this controversial episode parents hated
the show
Disney sitcoms are known for their
subtle humor that sometimes goes over
kids heads but if you're an adult you
probably raised an eyebrow several times
while watching the show did you know
that a lot of parents out there actually
hated Jessie when it comes to Disney
Channel shows you'll find a lot of
opinions from parent bloggers who just
can't understand why their kids can't
watch something different Jessie follows
the life of Jessie Prescott who moves to
New York and becomes a nanny for an
extremely wealthy family seems like a
pretty normal sitcom right but this show
seems to rub the parents in the wrong
way from subtle jokes to some of the
most offensive comments Jessie had
several controversial moments but most
of them weren't noticed by the young
fans as the seasons went by and we got
to see more of Jessie parents complain
the show is modeling horrible behavior
that children definitely shouldn't learn
or think it's funny in the first place
we'll talk more about how Jessie had
several jokes that probably shouldn't be
in a kid's program later there seemed to
have also been an issue with parents
being portrayed as the people who really
don't know anything sure it's a kids
show but if you can't appeal the parents
they won't let their kids watch it do
you think they're exaggerating or was
this show really that bad
many innuendos Disney is not a stranger
when it comes to innuendos and subtle
jokes in some of your favorite childhood
shows as kids we never noticed these but
we bet if you look back you'll see
plenty of subtle jokes and innuendos
Jessie is no exception from but touching
and having too much fun on dates to
wandering fingers and comments like son
of a biscuit Jessie subtle jokes are
probably way too subtle for children we
bet you'd be able to catch way more of
these jokes when you're older parents
have also pointed out that the show
jokes about girls stuffing their bras
instead of promoting positive body image
regardless of your size the show also
had jokes about possible mental illness
when a character mentioned they're
saving up for a car so they can run
themselves over in the first episode
Luke also pulls down his pants and tells
Emma he'll show him the moon besides not
promoting positive body image the show
also highlights character stereotypes
and frequently makes fun of looks and
other behaviors while we all know that
Jessie is not an educational channel
parents think there should be an
inspiring value to this show is Disney
taking things too far with these
innuendos or is it all just simply
innocent humor which we've seen in
plenty of other TV shows a resting
just a year after the show enough about
the show let's dive into some serious
secrets from our favourite Jesse stars
we've all seen several Disney stars
spiral out of control through the years
from Lindsay Lohan and her troubles with
the law - Demi Lovato and her battle
with her mental illness
it looks like being a child actor comes
with a price debby ryan also had her
share of controversial mishaps but one
of the most notable ones was her arrest
that happened just a year after the
show's final air date debbie describes
herself as a nerd but this nerd totally
failed her sobriety test after she
crashed her car into a Mercedes she was
arrested and put on a 100-thousand
dollar bail which is a lot of money
debbie is since then apologized for her
reckless decisions and said she does
realize that she's in fact a role model
to many she also had to complete
community service and to a three-month
program that focuses on highlighting the
dangers of driving under the influence
and although this incident happened
after jesse was already over it
certainly makes parents raise even more
eyebrows and wonder if this Disney star
is actually a good role model for their
children
since then debbie decided to shake off
her disney label and started focusing on
acting opportunities outside of the
disney channel did debbie date cole
sprouse while this is definitely not a
dark secret it's a secret many fans have
been dying to know whether or not it's
true is it a friendship or a
relationship debby ryan and cole sprouse
sparked several rumors over the years if
you've been following Debbie's career
you know she played bailey pickett on
the suite life on deck before her star
role in Jesse over the years on the show
Debbie and Cole got fairly close their
characters Bailey and Cody did actually
like each other but did they actually
date in real life the show ended back in
2011 and in 2017
Debbie posted a hilarious tweet joking
about Cole bringing a sequined fanny
pack to a themed music night the
hilarious list of what could possibly be
in Cole's fanny pack brought back a lot
of feels for the ultimate suite life on
deck fans if you've seen the show you
know Kayleigh really is the cutest
couple ever do we want them to date
absolutely are they actually dating
who knows Debbie actually admitted she
fangirled over dylan and Cole Sprouse
before she became an actress which is
just the cutest thing ever
at some point Cole also casually came
over to Debbie's house to meet her
kittens and they've had several reunions
that made our hearts melt just eight
already why don't you Debby Ryan's dark
friendships
Debbie's friendships also took a dark
turn after she shared a very serious
insight into her love life in 2015 when
Debbie was just 21 and Jesse just
wrapped its final episode Debbie opened
up in a people interview and talked
about her long abusive relationship she
never revealed the name but Debbie
talked about how her friendship turned
into a very emotionally and physically
abusive relationship that was hard to
get out of she spoke of how it went on
for a couple of years and it's safe to
say it also occurred while she was still
filming Jessi so while she looked happy
and bubbly on the show Debbie said it
took a while to realize that what was
happening to her wasn't in fact healthy
she described her experience as
frightening and mentioned this person
would call her up to 40 times per day
when she wouldn't be around him there
were lifelong friends but things came to
an end when her friend threatened to end
his life if she wouldn't spend time with
him Debbie also shared the backlash she
received for talking about her
relationship her ex-boyfriend reached
out to her and criticized her for daring
to speak up about the issue because he
was afraid the public would think it was
him on the other hand for now former
friend also reached out to her and
apologized did the show take it too far
but let's go back to the actual show
along with many innuendos and pulling a
controversial episode Disney seemed to
have taken its humor just a bit too far
with Jesse Disney isn't exactly known to
be culturally sensitive and openly mocks
topics that have to do with culture
religion and sometimes even physical
looks you've probably heard of a saying
that it takes a village to raise a child
so when Jesse aired an episode where an
Indian character jokes he's a human
samosa it raised a lot of questions
whether or not joking about such things
should be acceptable in a children's TV
show a blogger who watched this episode
with her young daughters mentioned how
uncomfortable they were when the scene
aired another common joke and Jesse was
the way the cast treated nanny Agatha
the British nanny who tried to keep
everyone in check the show frequently
mocks her looks and while Agatha wasn't
exactly the nicest character many have
pointed out that this is just another
stab at racial stereotyping and making a
joke out of certain cultures and
personalities racial stereotyping is
very common in Disney's shows but should
it be once again this is one of the
show's biggest controversies but even
though parents have pointed about many
times
Disney refused to acknowledge the issue
why did it end earlier the team behind
Jesse planned to make the show one of
the longest-running Disney Channel shows
but that crown still belongs to Wizards
of Waverly Place and it's 106 episodes
so why did Jesse and after 98 episodes
it's still not clear why the show got
cancelled in the first place and when a
fan directly tweeted at debby asking her
that same question she responded that
the show ran its course and hit 100
episodes you have to admit that the show
was pretty impressive even though it
didn't reach their end goal and got
canceled it seems like everyone was just
ready to move on to new adventures
including Cameron Boyce who had to make
an important career decision we'll talk
more about his character and his
relationship with Debbie Ryan in a bit
if you are looking for some iconic
Disney Channel shows outside of Jessie
make sure you check out Wizards of
Waverly Place
Kim Possible good luck charlie and
that's so raven which was the
longest-running show before Wizards of
Waverly Place while Jesse did have its
memorable moments do you think it could
really beat such iconic Disney Channel
shows as That's So Raven we're pretty
sure that the last reason on our list is
the main responsibility for Jesse's
abrupt ending Cameron voice let's take a
moment and talk about Cameron Boyce the
eye candy on the show who played Luke
Ross Luke was 11 years old in season 1
and 16 by the time they aired season 4
jesse was so popular it actually got its
own spin-off show called Punk'd but the
show didn't focus on Jessie Bertram and
Luke but there's a reason why these
characters weren't able to star in the
show Cameron Boyce actually starred in
Disney XD
gamers guide to pretty much everything
and had to choose between the show and
bunked he chose the gamers guide and
that was it for Jesse's eye candy do you
think bunk'd would be even more
successful and continued Jesse's
popularity if it featured characters
like Jessie Bertram and Luke the show is
still going strong in 2017 but some fans
do miss seeing the old Jesse cast back
together Cameron Boyce and Debbie
actually have a very sweet friendship
but do you think there's a deeper reason
why Cameron chose another Disney show
rather than going back to the original
Jesse cast well we can definitely tell
you that the show had a surprising Feud
we never saw coming
but according to celebrity gossip Debbie
had a few intense words to share about
another Jesse star debby ryan and skye
jackson feud and here it is one of the
biggest controversies of the jesse show
that shed light on the acting world and
how not everything is as it seems
while debby ryan is actually really good
friends with her ex co-stars like
Cameron Boyce it's unclear where she
stands with Skye Jackson a child actress
who plays Zuri Ross on the show
Zuri is also one of the main characters
in the Jessie spin-off Punk'd but did
you know that she and Debby didn't
actually get along at the beginning of
Jessie the two were really close and
showed off cute photos on social media
but in 2014 Skye unfollowed Debbie on
Twitter fans started to wonder what's
happening between the two and it looks
like they haven't exactly mended their
friendship Skye seemed to have a secret
Twitter account that claimed Debbie
actually bullied her on the show but
after the rumor had broken out Skye
confirmed Debbie was rude to her on her
main Twitter account in an awkward
interview Skye was also asked about
Debbie and answered that they just went
their separate ways and do their own
thing Debbie of course fired back at
Skye's bullying claims in a long tumblr
post Debbie addressed the issue and said
she wishes every child actor would have
emotional security and complete content
Skye posted a Jessie throw back shortly
after and blurred out Debbie's face on
the picture whatever the feud was it
looks like the Tuesday
haven't patched it up in 2016 could this
be the main reason why Jesse got
canceled so early don't forget to click
that like button and subscribe to our
channel for more videos like this one
make sure to check out 10 deleted Disney
Princesses and rejected concepts see you
next time
[Music]